l'idéologie sans le pouvoir c'est de la
vanité à dire une auto dans cet extrait
d'une déclaration qu'il a envoyée sur
facebook un peu plus tôt aujourd'hui
chantal hébert à la question gay leur
budget ti bon soin qu'est-ce que vous
avez compris de cette petite phrase que
j'ai trouvé intéressante chantal
qu'il aurait eu intérêt à s'en servir
avant aujourd'hui
parce que c'était le message que stephen
harper et preston manning avant lui ont
utilisé pour essayer de convaincre
l'élément réformiste tu mouvement
conservateur que les petites batailles
celle qu'on gagne à l'intérieur valent
pas vraiment grand chose si on a ce
faisant on se disqualifie pour former un
gouvernement
malheureusement pour monsieur o toole
c'est pas ce que les députés ont rejeté
aujourd'hui parce que c'est pas le genre
de disque auxquelles il nous a habitués
ça arrivait trop tard elle est sur
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre
il a voulu manifestement envoyé ce
message là ces députés qui ont voté
contre lui
oui c'est le bon message à envoyer le
problème c'est pourtant le message que
le message et sadique la théorie à la
mode depuis quelques heures c'est que la
droite pure et dure du parti
conservateur a eu la tête de renault tôt
parce qu'il voulait recentrer le parti
se reposer que pour un peu de vrai là
dedans y'a surement effectivement des
gens à droite conservatrice qui ont pas
de l'aide sociale conservatrice qui ont
point misc risotto le fait mais grosso
modo et renault tôt c'est lui même qui a
tellement mal performé dans les derniers
mois qui a donné les arguments après
tout le monde cherchait à jouer sur tous
les tableaux on à la course à la
direction il était le vrai bleus est
proche de la base conservatrice s'est
même fait des appels du pied à la base
sociale conservatrice ensuite il veut
recentrer le parti essaie de parler à
ceux qui sont beaucoup plus madero
partie même avec les camionneurs on
essaie de dire qu'on n'est pas d'accord
avec la manifestation me retrouve une
manière d'aller parler aux camionneurs
on a essayé de faire plaisir tellement à
tout le monde chez renault toki le des
plu à tout le monde et c'est en fait en
sorte que le message était brouillé
kebede députés qui disait bon on peut
pas continuer comme ça donc ils voyent
aaron guerre idéologique au sein de ce
parti c'est inévitable à chacune des
courses à la direction - oui on s'est
repenti conservatoire mais fallait
d'abord que l'aide avant voici le
message était capable de continuer les
députés ont jugé que non donc ya pas
réussi vous dites à faire la synthèse de
ces courants différents que forme le
parti conservateur et l'inde n'ont
évidemment il n'a pas réussi c'était un
message cette phrase que vous avez fait
de jouer à un message de pragmatisme
mais lui-même monsieur o'toole n'a
peut-être pas fait preuve d'un
pragmatisme c'est bon c'est sûr que
c'est facile à dire maintenant
aujourd'hui mais avec le recul je me
demande s'il se dit pas que en décembre
plutôt que d'expulser sa sénatrice de
nice bat us dont le crime était de dire
devant son le vote de confiance envers
notre chef qui est prévue en 2003 c'est
à dire juste un peu avant une possible
échéances électorales devant son honneur
pour qu'on règle cette question une fois
pour toutes monsieur autour l'avait
expulsé maintenant on ce soir il doit se
diront si j'avais plutôt que
j'avais acquiescé à cette idée on n'en
serait pas là parce qu'il faut quand
même souligner l'ironie de la situation
parti conservateur qui de tout temps
s'est présenté comme un parti de la base
à 1 grâce rude partie comme on dit en
anglais qui est très connecté sur ses
membres mais voici que ce parti de qui
avait 270 mille membres lors de la
course la dernière course au leadership
et bien ce parti réussit à déloger son
chef seulement avec la vie de 73 députés
c'est quand même particulier oui c'est
la première fois qu'on utilise ce
mécanisme chantal est ce que vous le
trouvez qu il est efficace dans la
mesure où le couperet tombe pas à peu
près est ce qui est une arme qui seront
davantage utilisés ou ce une arme
atomique on veut pas utiliser mais qu'on
a utilisé la camp vous voyez ce nouvel
outil là
qu'elle soit occupé la tête c'est
toujours mieux avec un ep bien aiguisé
et ce principe là vous pouvez voir et
regarder les séries sur
ce ce
mécanisme al'avantage d'arriver au même
résultat plus rapidement parce que quand
un caucus perd la confiance en son chef
et là je vais vous donner quelques
exemples
sans cette loi-là stockwell day alors il
ya une demi douzaine de députés et pas
les moindres qui quitte le parti qui
s'en vont siéger avec les progressistes
conservateurs de l'époque et donc à la
fin on avait au même résultat jean
chrétien et paul martin quitte le
cabinet et on commence à parler d'un
vote de confiance il monsieur chrétien
finalement efforcé de mettre d'accord
son leadership john turner je suis plus
vieille que les autres j'ai passé je ne
sais plus combien de mots aléas des
caucus calculer combien de coups de
canif ça allait prendre
alors
à la fin on a ou on n'a pas la confiance
qu aucune cession de la peau mais c'est
mieux que ça se règle très bien on va
écouter quelques réactions aujourd'hui
pour reviennent mettez moi et voir
également une pensée pour mon collègue
le député de durham dont je salue la
sincérité et la rigueur de l'engagement
[Musique]
avec la satisfaction totale à dormir
élections il ya beaucoup de joueurs qui
pensaient que j'étais trop d'où étaient
étaient prêts à quitter leur maillot du
parti du bureau du pays ce que moi du
canada mais on n'a pas réussi articulé
je pense le bon message certains vous
ont été satisfaits course des
différentes franges qu'on a dans notre
organisation parce qu'on est une grande
coalition donc déjà été satisfait du
message des changements je dirais de cap
qui avait été enclenchée après la course
à la chefferie dans ce recentrage du
parti cette modernisation donc il y
avait des frictions et je pense que bon
il n'y a pas réussi à
unir
lumbres
[Musique]
on va partir
je faisais
[Musique]
ça donne mais bien
dès à présent
[Musique]
bonne chance vous avez compris mais
déduction idée on n'est pas un parti
divisé mais il y avait des intentions je
pose la question je nous projette dans
l'avenir
est ce que c'est possible c'est pas le
même contexte que monsieur harper avait
devant lui monsieur mulroney est ce que
c'est possible pour quelqu'un pour
quelques unes de dire voici le carré
dans lequel on va on va agir puis venez
avec moi puis on s'en va battre les
libéraux aux dents dans quatre ans
écoutez ça dépendra beaucoup de la durée
de cette course au leadership et tout
indique où tout porte à croire qu'elle
ne sera pas très longue le défi si on
veut véritablement recentrer ce parti et
il m'apparaît évident que c'est en le
recentrant qu'on peut gagner une
élection pour recentrer le parti il faut
augmenter le nombre de membres allaient
chercher des membres à l'extérieur de
l'alberta de la saskatchewan sortir de
ce bassin de personnes un peu plus
radicale dans leurs opinions
conservatrices si vous voulez et
rappelez-vous jean charest qu'est-ce qui
le dit quand il a décidé de ne pas aller
dans la course eh bien il le dit
justement s'est dit je manque de temps
pour recruter ces orphelins politiques
qui sont peut-être bleus dans l'armée
qui ne se retrouvent pas dans le parti
conservateur actuel je manque de temps
pour les convaincre d'acheter une carte
de membre votez pour moi est donc
enclenché ce recentrage alors j'ai un
peu peur qu'on se retrouve encore avec
une course très courte et que intel
recentrage ne soit donc pas possible ok
avec
plus on est longtemps loin du pouvoir
plus des gens qui sont prêts à faire des
compromis c'était l'époque de stephen
harper où il y aurait chez les
convaincre que le droite divisée allait
servir à rien
le on du côté des conservateurs perdu
les deux dernières élections peut-être
déjà qu'ils vont effectivement penser
qu'on a besoin de position un peu plus
moderne sur des questions qui touchent
maintenant profondément les canadiens je
pense à l'environnement entre autres est
une question importante
ça sera pas nécessairement facile parce
que la base conservatrice lavage de tous
les partis elle est comme ça elle est
facilement influençable par des coups de
gueule mais faudra que le prochain
leader s'il veut vraiment recentrer le
parti soit honnête avec la base puis
qu'on arrête de faire semblant comme le
faire une auto lequel est quasiment voté
pour nous quand on fait des vidéos
disant que les libéraux s'apprête à
mettre fin aux formes d'énergie
des tirs et des vidéos complètement pas
comme ça qu'ils sont d'abord faux mais
en plus qui sait absolument rien plaisir
à la base c'est pas comme ça qu'on
attire des nouveaux électeurs au parti
conservateur dont il faudra les
convaincre on a des cons premier à faire
je suis d'accord avec elle est peut-être
que plus la course est court plus c'est
difficile à faire mais en même temps si
on veut être un parti qui aspire à
gouverner il faudra qu'ils les
conservateurs trouver de manière d'y
arriver ouais chantal
côte ou longues je vous fais remarquer
qu andrew scheer et aéronautique sont
devenus chef du parti conservateur à la
fin grâce à l'appui de du tiers des gens
qui ont voté qui s'identifiaient des
candidats de la droite religieuse
premièrement et que la majorité des
délégués au dernier congrès du parti
conservateur à la veille d'une élection
ont refusé une résolution qui disait que
la lutte aux changements climatiques
c'était quelque chose dans lequel il
fallait s'engager alors
mettez ces deux groupes là ensemble et
oui on gagnera pas des élections comme
ça mais un parti qui veut se faire
plaisir si on en a vu d'autres on sait
où ça mène la clé bout les néo
démocrates après que c'est con j'ai dit
monsieur mon coeur se lisait on reprend
le contrôle de notre parti peut-être que
c'était vrai mais regardez où ils sont
ouais mais donc je vous écoute puis si
ce même parti qui n'a effectivement lors
de son dernier congrès pas voulu
reconnaître les changements climatiques
se donne un chef qui va vouloir aller
dans le sens du vent de ce parti là bas
le pouvoir il va s'éloigner à mesure
qu'ils vont avancer
une chose qui me qui peut peut-être joué
en leur faveur si la course est courte
donc je me contredis peut-être en
apparence le mexique c'est si il ya
beaucoup moins de candidats y est c'est
un patton qu'on a vu avec le parti
conservateur mais aussi avec le parti
libéral si on s'en souvient c'est à dire
que lorsque beaucoup beaucoup de
candidats il ya toujours évidemment un
candidat préféré ça a été maxime bernier
dans une course dans l'autre c'était
monsieur peter mackay puis chez les
libéraux c'est un certain mike golding
natif mais c'est préférer la ou bien on
les aime bien on les aime pas du tout
ils ne sont pas notre deuxième choix et
parce que c'est un système d'un vote
préférentiel ses préférés leur plafonne
et à mesure que les taux passent et ben
c'est les candidats qui était arrivé 2e
3e voire même 4e lors du premier tour
qu'on finisse par coiffer le préférez
les récents chantant lui la
rappelez-vous
non non je suis en désaccord néanmoins
ce système la donne et stéphane guillon
et l'autre système à donner michael
ignatieff alors tu pas convaincu qu'il
ya une boîte solution que dans moins de
candidats c'est la première randonnée
c'est oui mais néanmoins la deuxième
fois un seul candidat s'est adonné
michael ignatieff est la troisième
classe qui va plonger avec qui va
plonger tour de table qui va plonger
d'après vous là il ya un an le ceppol
mais tout le plonge ses c'est la bonne
question est ce qu'on laisse la voie
libre à quelqu'un en espérant que ce
personnel soit le sauveur je pense à
bien poilievre était bien des jeux des
militants conservateurs aiment beaucoup
moi je suis pas certain que c'est le
genre de candidat qui peut élargir la
base conservatrice mais ça va être à eux
de décider est ce qu'on va voir des
candidatures externes des gens qui ont
passé leur tour la dernière fois parce
qu'en 2017 2018 on avait l'impression
qu'il était imbattable justin trudeau
qui est cette fois ci après trois
mandats personnel et un quatrième depuis
wilfrid laurier ça va être difficile
pour tous 2010 les candidats
intéressants qui pourraient cette fois
ci être tentés d'y aller donc qui
viendrait de l'extérieur honnêtement il
très tôt très tôt pour voir un peu qui
va se lancer mais je leur souhaite
d'avoir des candidats de l'extérieur qui
viennent les bras c'est un petit peu
puis qui la ramène quelque chose
d'intéressant dans une course à la
direction chantal
il n'y aura pas jason kenny nerbonne
d'oxford le premier ministre thériault
et rapport à un brusque des je dis non
oui et non et
toujours pour dire que dans le moment
les deux noms pour longtemps c'est
l'hymne russe cette candidate à ces
unilingue anglaise qui a été élu député
et qui se revendique de la droite
religieuse et puis un poignet et en
passant le principal l'ancien abord
comment aujourd'hui à boisé sur les
médias sociaux en soit on est débarrassé
de monsieur ou toulalan ça donne une
idée de l'ambiance hélène ça donne une
ambiance exactement mais j'attends le
doigt dessus mais c'est aussi parce que
quand ça fait trois courses qu'on a
c'est un sixième année on épuise le
bassin de candidats intéressants
potentiel et le simple fait que ici ce
soir nous trois on a de la difficulté à
vous proposer des noms qui circulent ça
témoigne l'un d'eux un peu le désert qui
devant eux et tous moi ce que j'en
entends beaucoup chez les conservateurs
c'est qu'à l'intérieur on voit pierre
poilievre comme un rockstar je suis ici
et j'avoue que ça m'étonne énormément
sur ce personnage politique est certes
peut-être très efficace mais c'est un
teigneux c'est un hargneux pas
nécessairement l'image du conservatisme
moderne un peu plus ouvert et centristes
qu'on veut envoyer alors j'ai un peu
l'impression que les partis
conservateurs fort de sa de sa victoire
aujourd'hui sur leur chef trop centrés
va peut-être continuer dans une voie qui
ne lui sera pas bénéfique à long terme
ce sera un devoir aucun mot sur ottawa
hélène on n'attend pas les claques sion
sa méthode ne sont pas loin du succès au
studio où l'on vient de dévoiler sa dit
aujourd'hui écouter les amis l'on va pas
rentrer dans le top cédé 18 roupies il
est incertain il faut que la solution
soit politique a dit aux élus de la
ville d'ottawa le chef de police
d'ottawa tour de table chantal comment
vous voyez ce siège qui se poursuit
ottawa il celui qui arrive peut-être à
québec
premièrement clairement la police
d'ottawa mauvaise évaluation ils ont
laissé
des poids lourds s'installer dans des
endroits stratégiques de la ville
d'ottawa et deuxièmement je suis pas sûr
qu'ils voulaient dire que c'est la
solution devrait être politique puisque
dans le même point de presse il ya aussi
parlé de l'armée ou de la
jirga est dispo moi croyons musique et
ses ponts et sait pas quoi faire
premièrement deuxièmement j'imagine que
les autorités policières les forces de
l'ordre la ville de québec mais aussi
les questions de toronto en passant ont
pris des notes et vont agir possiblement
différemment
de la porte ouverte qu'on installe et on
laisse pas aussi des gens qui a
provisionné le siège puisque c'est comme
ça que la police la perle et il passe
les barrages policiers c'est pas un
problème puis les approvisionnent
provisions et sens à un moment donné il
va falloir décider si c'est d'un siège
et là on y compte les bureaux non grain
oui on s'en parlait plus tôt cette
semaine patrice sur la question ne
vont-ils manqué d'essence je suis allé
aux frères informations depuis vous
savez des 18 roues justement ça des
réservoirs de 5 600 lits depuis six ans
d'un double ses 1200 litres si on se met
sur idol je me suis informé on peut
rouler à peu près trois semaines avec
des réservoirs pleins comme ça donc ils
ne viendront pas à court d'essence ce
qu'ils ont et vont camions les plus
petits wilser hachage le mais alors il
ya un endroit près du stade de baseball
où ils vont se ravitailler puis
reviennent pour les laisse passer
effectivement comme chantal voilà plus
petit véhicule mais pour les gros ils
sont très autonomes et donc et ça pose
un défi
matériel réel et pas beaucoup de monde
pour de l'équipement pour remorquer ce
genre de
véhicule pas ce qu'il faut pour faire
recours à l'armée est ça évidemment
c'est quelque chose c'est toujours pas
au gouvernement très important ce que
vous me dire que nous prenons savoir mon
autre me savard
ya pas un entrepreneur privé qui dès
taurines que kiki remorqueur qui va
aller remorquer un de ses collègues
oubliez ça alec 30 secondes le maire de
québec entre lui lance l'avertissement
ils disent pas vrai qu'on va les laisser
entrer au tour du parlement que vu ce
qui est arrivé à ottawa
c'est clairement un enseignement pour
québec où on devrait les amener à un
endroit où il ne nuiront pas il peut
manifester est un droit qui est
important aujourd'hui rompue à
l'ensemble la ville de québec ce qu'on a
vraiment complètement échappé à ottawa
les revendications politiques absolument
aucune revendication que tu peux être
qui peut être mise en place par le
gouvernement fédéral on peut mettre les
mesures sanitaires complètement on peut
lever les mesures sanitas et les
provinces qui décide si la vaccination
obligatoire des titres à des camionneurs
les états unis l'exigent ou 6 à lens
politique cette crise ne se réglera pas
d'une manière politique merci à vous
trois bonnes soirées à revoir au revoir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit